[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
rugby une qualification historique pour
plaisir les joueurs de gens se sont
imposés sur terrain neutre contre au ris
orangis en huitièmes de finale de
fédérale 3 une large victoire 25 à 0 qui
prend tout sens car pour vautours plus
d'informations à suivre
tennis en plein à roland garros coup de
projecteur sur le club de plaisir la
structure qu'on plus de 900 adhérents
organise chaque année un tournoi futures
la troisième plus grosse compétition
tennistique en ile-de-france les détails
dans cette édition taekwondo rencontre
avec jeanne à haïti étudiante en et de
la faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
elle vient de décrocher le titre de
championne de france universitaire à
orléans nous lui avons posé trois
questions reprendre replants à présent
sur les principaux résultats du week-end
dans le département
[Musique]
avant de développer ces titres nous
allons prendre la direction de trappes
pour parler football l'équipe seniors de
l'étoile sportive a terminé sa saison ce
week-end par une victoire 2 à 1 sur le
terrain des gobelins résultat qui leur
permet de terminer la saison à la 5e
place du classement à neuf points du
leader boulogne billancourt et je vais
en resteront donc en promotion d'honneur
à la saison prochaine enfin la fin de
saison rime souvent avec départ du côté
les joueurs aucun mouvement n'est prévue
pour le moment
par contre ça devrait bouger au niveau
de la direction l'emblématique président
du club mustapha larbaoui white lesquels
va quitter son poste
l'homme qui a passé 14 années à la tête
de la structure doit l'annoncer ce lundi
29 mai au club nous explique son choix
moi si j'ai souhaité m'arrêter cette
année c'est parce que j'ai toujours eue
c'était l'idée qu' il fallait jamais été
très longtemps surtout trop longtemps 14
ans c'est à la fois très peu quand on
imagine qu'on peut rester jusqu'à 30 ans
dans des structures
et en même temps c'est pour moi une
limite important parce que ça correspond
à une génération
pour moi ça s'arrête là parce que j'ai
vraiment besoin de de me retrouver d'une
part d'autre part mes parents ont besoin
de moi et ça c'est majeur pour moi on se
rend compte que les choses vont vite ce
que j'aime et en même temps il ya des
choses qu'on risquerait de laisser
passer et
je voudrais surtout va passer à côté de
certaines choses importantes toujours en
football c'était le match de la peur
dans le championnat excellence maurepas
recevait verneuil pour l'ultime
rencontre de la saison
en cas de défaite l'équipe descendait
dans la division inférieure et ce sont
finalement les mots repas indien qui
resteront en excellence la saison
prochaine ils ont emporté 2 à 1 et
termine finalement la 9e place sur 11
équipes avec seulement deux petits
points d'avancé sur le premier relégable
on continue à part du rugby et la très
belle performance de plaisir ce week-end
en huitièmes de finale de fédérale 3 sur
terrain neutre à houilles les plaisirs
wac déjà assurés de la montée la saison
prochaine en terrasse et ris orangis
dans un match à sens unique le score 25
à 0 le montage est signée pascal josèphe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les iris y en blanc s'est brillamment
qualifié pour les quarts de finale de
fédérale 3 une première dans l'histoire
du club avec trois essais inscrits le
plaisir ont étouffé leurs adversaires de
la première à la 80e minute pour
l'emporter 25 à 0 on a su marquer la
nommant un homme fort on a été reçus à
être pragmatique on a super bien des
fans ont surtout selon même faible on a
été là on a été présent on n'a rien
lâché aujourd'hui
tout nous a souri mais la chatte se
sourit aux audacieux c'est ce qu'on dit
toujours mais c'est vrai que ben voilà
le résultat est là c'est que on a fait
des supers
c'est super super action de jeu l'une
des principales satisfactions de la
journée à la défense pour la quatrième
fois de la saison plaisir n'a concédé
aucun point
on a vraiment 1015 ouvrage en termes
d'agressivité on était vraiment présent
bien organisé c'est quelque chose qu'on
travaille depuis quelques temps et je
pense que ce qu'a payé aux vaudois
au prochain tour les plaisirs hu
affronteront tour une équipe que les ivy
wahhabite affronter en fédérale 2 en
2015 on sait que c'est bien organisé
donc il ya même pas penser au titre
aujourd'hui faut prendre les matches
comme ils viennent il faut jouer jojo il
faut les jouer
on verra ce qui se passe c'est ce qu'on
a fait aujourd'hui le match contre tours
sera programmée le 11 juin prochain sur
terrain neutre en attendant plaisir peut
savourer le club fait partie des huit
meilleures équipes du championnat sur
160 clubs engagés
[Musique]
il y avait du baseball la semaine
dernière à montigny le bretonneux
l'équipe locale des cougars a organisé
pour la troisième fois de son histoire
le challenge de france au stade jean
maréchal l'une des plus grosses
compétitions de baseball dans l'hexagone
avec à la clé une place pour la coupe
d'europe les huit équipes de première
division se sont affrontés entre
montigny le bretonneux et rouen on
écoute la présidente des cougars annie
couton elle était au micro de stéphane
servant nous avons organisé à montigny
parce que nous avons été sollicités par
wacom terrain partenaires de plus cette
année le club de montigny remontait en
dea c'était aussi une façon de montrer à
notre public
la nouvelle naissance de notre équipe de
d1
nous avons recruté des étrangers c'était
aussi l'occasion que tout le monde
puisse les voir jouer pendant deux jours
après une belle victoire contre sénart
les cougars se sont inclinés contre le
muc barracuda baseball et donc et dans
le deuxième match contre les templiers
de senna les futurs vainqueurs du
challenge de france conséquence pas de
coupe d'europe pour montigny le
bretonneux
on ouvre à présent une page tennis en
plein roland garros gros plan
aujourd'hui sur le club de tennis de
plaisir la structure créée en 1972 est
aujourd'hui considérée comme l'une des
meilleures de france avec plus de 900
licenciés les images sont signés à
nicolas d'ombré bienvenue au tennis-club
de plaisir
l'un des clubs les plus importants de
notre ligue
voir le club connu et reconnu dans tout
l'hexagone charger d'hanoï président du
tennis-club de plaisir depuis 1989 le
dirigeant a vu la structure se
transformer depuis sa création en 1972
après avoir débuté avec deux courts
aujourd'hui les 957 adhérents peuvent
pratiquer leur passion sur six courts
couverts 10 courts extérieurs dont
quatre en terre battue semblable à un
rang garros qui dit ralentissement du
jeu dit
technique qui peut être développer d'une
façon un peu plus comme un pointu si je
perds et tu verras si vous voyez donc
c'est pour cette raison que ces terres
sont vraiment un atout supplémentaire
pour notre club pour obtenir des
résultats en adéquation avec son
infrastructure le club n'a pas hésité à
recruter cinq enseignants diplômés
détail un directeur sportif une
politique qui payent le tennis club a
sorti de nombreux talents comme mika
llodra qui a fréquenté le club de
plaisir pendant deux ans
je ne dis pas ça parce que c'est mon
club et tous les gens dans leur école de
tennis il ya des frontières et qui
sortent tous les ans nous avons déjà
mais qu'ils sont qui vont disputer les
championnats de france à roland-garros
donc elle a ce chez notre fierté plaisir
organise également un tournoi futures
doté de 25 mille dollars avec
hébergement des joueurs
c'est le seul tournoi en ile de france
de cette catégorie
hormis évidemment roland garros et bercy
évidemment c'est plus de 800
compétiteurs qui défilent au mois de
septembre et si les dates du tournoi
sont déjà connus les joueurs
s'affronteront du 15 au 24 septembre
l'occasion de voir peut être les futures
pépites plaisir oise qui brilleront sur
les courts de tennis dans les prochaines
années
on continue de parler tennis dans ce
magazine roland garros a donc débuté ce
dimanche 28 mai du côté de la porte
d'auteuil cette année pas divine oit
dans le tournoi du grand chelem et plus
de 200 joueurs venus du monde entier
dans le tableau masculin on retrouvera
une nouvelle fois le serbe novak
djokovic et rafael nadal 9 fois champion
sur la terre battue parisienne qui est
le grand favori pour cette nouvelle
édition nous avons posé la question au
club de plaisir ben moi je pense que
c'est rafael nadal qui a gagné roland
garros bascule en ce moment est vraiment
fort roland garros je verrais bien
rafael nadal cette année je pense qu'il
aura à coeur de rentrer vraiment dans
l'histoire pour un bon moment et je le
vois bien faire dix fois roland garros
donc je pense l année où il à vouloir
tout donner
et ça sera peut-être la dernière donc je
pense que vraiment il va il va
s'arracher peut-être plus que les années
précédentes
donc je miserais bien rafael nadal cette
année je pense qu'il ya deux favoris
je pense que djokovic va venir avec
agassi et va peut-être il va peut-être
vous surprendre mais il y à nadal qui
est là et nadal à mon avis est favori un
mot de golf maintenant et de la ryder
cup 2018 à un peu moins de 500 jours du
début de la compétition un nouvel
ambassadeur a été désigné après le
skipper armel le cléac'h vainqueur du
dernier vendée globe c'est un autre nom
prestigieux qui viendra fouler les
greens du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines en septembre 2018 le
footballeur ballon d'or 2004 andrei
shevchenko le sportif vainqueur de la
ligue des champions a été nommé
ambassadeur de la team europe pour la
compétition grand passionné de golf
depuis plusieurs années il aura cette
occasion un rôle avant tout symbolique
il pourrait notamment participé à la
cérémonie d'ouverture
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler d' escalade dans ce magazine pour
la deuxième année consécutive
l'entreprise verticale art implantée
dans la zone du pas du lac à montigny le
bretonneux organiser une grande
compétition ce samedi 27 mai baptisé
verticale night les meilleurs grimpeurs
du moment se sont affrontés sur les
blocs de la structure pendant les
qualifications et les finales on écoute
l'un des géants l'objectif en fait c'est
sur une seule journée c'est 2
enfin une compétition avec une partie
qualification avoir plusieurs catégories
amateurs
un professionnel donc
les abonnés au sida salle pour le
convier justement à se confronter aux
meilleurs l'objectif
la gare hier d'organiser une journée
complète autour du sport
nous allons maintenant parler de sport
de combat et plus précisément de
taekwondo coup de projecteur sur johanna
haïti
étudiante en l2 à la faculté de droit et
de sciences politiques à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
elle vient de décrocher le titre de
championne de france universitaire à
orléans la sportive ceinture noire 1re
dan est donc qualifié pour les
championnats d'europe au portugal qui se
dérouleront en juillet nous lui avons
posé trois questions
le tpo ndo pourquoi c'est mon papa qui
m'a inscrit à l'âge de 8 ans il était
passionné par les arts martiaux
du coup une pâle est un sport de défense
je pense quand j'ai commencé à inscrire
à la fac j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
secteur sport ensuite j'ai vu qu'on sur
le site sur le site de la fédération de
taekwondo qu'on pouvait participer aux
championnats de france universitaires
donc j'ai été faire les démarches j'ai
été me renseigner auprès de pierre nieto
le directeur des sports et c'est lui qui
m'a dit qu'on ne pouvait pas lier
prendre la licence universitaire et
c'est comme ça qu après je suis rentré
dans le cursus universitaire
j'essaie de m'entraîner entre trois et
quatre fois par semaine donc dans mon
club on peut s'entraîner pratiquement
tous les jours mais moi je m'entraîne
j'essaie de m'entraîner trois à quatre
fois par semaine à l'entraînement type c
on s'échauffe pendant à peu près une
demi heure ensuite on s'étire et puis un
entraînement combat ensuite on fait des
techniques sur un plastron ou un pas ou
une raquette et puis après on peut
terminer par des routes
grâce à ces championnats de france donc
grâce à ce titre j'ai été sélectionné
pour les championnats d'europe au
portugal donc au mois de juillet et du
coup mon objectif ça serait de monter
sur la plus haute marche du podium pour
les championnats d'europe
c'est la consécration de quinze années
de travail ça fait quinze ans que du thé
cuando donc cela fait mais c'est la
consécration de 15 ans de travail on
passe maintenant notre rubrique agenda
[Musique]
un mot de boxe pour commencer cet agenda
avec le premier combat professionnel
tant attendu de l'illinois tony hawk eye
sportifs originaires de chanteloup les
vignes champion olympique des poids
super lourds défiera ce vendredi 2
jouant palais des sports de paris
l'américain travis clark un adversaire
qui a disputé douze combats pour 12
victoires dont 8 avant la limite
dans la même soirée le verrier roi ahmed
el moussaoui sera également sur le ring
pour un combat international des poids
mi-moyens contre le russe froman celi
bairstow si vous voulez assister au
match
il reste quelques places et puis en
balles le championnat de nationale 2
féminine se termine ce week-end le club
de montigny le bretonneux recevra pour
cette 22e et dernière journée le club de
noisy le grand
pour cette rencontre les i montaigne
sont favorites elle occupe actuellement
la quatrième place du championnat avec
deux points de retard sur la troisième
place en cas de victoire les joueuses
pourrait accrocher le podium dans cette
fin de saison
si vous voulez supporter les joueuses le
match est programmé ce samedi à 20h30 au
complexe sportif pierre de coubertin à
montigny le bretonneux
c'est la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi très belle semaine sur téléphiles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]